this video will walk through the process
of setting up a sagemaker domain with
access to our studio workbench so the
first thing we need to do is make sure
that we have access to an rstudio
license within AWS license manager so
navigate to that within the AWS console
there's two ways that you can have
access to a license here one is either
by purchasing an RCA workbench license
from the Amazon Marketplace the other is
by reaching out directly to rstudio and
requesting a license to be granted into
your account in the case that the
license has been granted you would need
to then accept that license so that's
something that needs to be done within
license manager in here I can see that I
have an rstudio workbench stagemaker
license that's available this is one
that's been granted I also have one that
came from the marketplace available in
this account as well so as long as you
have a license available for our studio
workbench either one that's been granted
to you by our studio or one that you've
purchased in the marketplace you can
then go through the setup process Within
sagemaker
after I've confirmed that I have a
license that's ready to go in license
manager I'll navigate to the sagemaker
landing page
here I can just click on get started and
then this will bring me to this place
where I can configure my sagemaker
domain I'm going to go ahead and set
that up I'm going to choose standard
setup here because I want to adjust a
few things
specifically related to the rstudio
workbench setup
here I can choose which authentication
mechanism I want to use set up a default
execution role there's one that
um that can be created for you if you
need to create an execution role in here
um one thing that's worth noting is in
order for you to have access to
the license that you that you have
inside of AWS license manager you'll
need to make sure that this particular
execution role has license manager
permissions there's some documentation
and details about that in a blog post by
Amazon but essentially you just need to
make sure that this execution role has
permission to read license manager
information so that it can pull the
license that you have for our studio
next we can choose a VPC subnets any you
know all the relevant different pieces
of information that we might want to set
up here
here's this is where we set up sagemaker
Studio I'm not going to dive too deeply
into this uh if you're using sagemaker
Studio you have some options here about
how that's set up and configured I'm
just going to leave all the defaults in
place and then the third step here are
the r Studio settings so you'll see that
it will automatically identify that you
have a workbench license detected and so
it will enable these options within your
sagemaker domain this first option here
is what instance type I want to run for
the persistent RC Studio workbench
environment a T3 medium is typically
sufficient this instance runs 24 7 but
if you choose a T3 medium which is the
default you don't pay for that instance
it's an instance that just that is just
provided for you by Amazon as part of
your sagemaker environment
then I need to choose an execution role
for my rstudio server in this case
there's this rc2 execution role that
I've previously created
if I want to pre-configure our studio
connect and rstudio package manager URLs
I can put those in here this would be
these become the default publication
endpoints and default package repository
within workbench once you've set that up
once I've gone through all these options
I can hit submit and then my domain will
be created this takes a few minutes for
the domain to to get up and running once
the domain is running
um the the next step that I need to go
through is ADD individual users onto the
domain which you can see here in the
users panel uh when I click on add user
it'll bring up a menu and one of the
things that I can do when I add a user
is determine what their uh what their
status is as an RCA workbench user
whether they are unauthorized a standard
user or an admin user and if I add them
as either a standard admin user it gives
them access to to access our studio
workbench
okay now the domain is ready we can go
ahead and go through this add user
process come in here choose some server
name I'll just choose my own name
Define an execution role
and then here again these are settings
related specifically to sagemaker Studio
which you can adjust if you want to and
then finally here's where I can choose
what I how I set this user up for our
studio specifically whether they're an
unauthorized user which prevents them
from accessing our studio in our studio
user which gives them standard access
and an R Studio admin which will provide
access to the admin dashboard within our
studio
once this user gets provisioned I can
use the drop down menu over here on the
right hand side to launch either studio
if I've given them access to that or
rstudio as I've given this user this
user access to again it'll take a moment
for the user profile to be created once
that's done I can select something like
our studio and I'll get dropped into an
RS studio session on sagemaker and I'm
ready to go
in this particular case we added this
user to the admin group so if I wanted
to I could come in and adjust the URL
and add admin at the end of it to gain
access to the admin dashboard for that
user as well
hopefully this helps get an idea of what
it takes to set up a sagemaker domain
with access to our studio thanks for
watching